[Música]
esta revista de prensa con Marta Moya en
directo a América Marta Buen día para
usted Buenos días Ángela vamos a abrir
la revista de prensa con la noticia del
día que no es otra que el anuncio a la
reelección de Joe biden en Estados
Unidos así es Ángela según el portal de
noticias políticas
aprobación en estos momentos del 52% y
hace poco más de un mes otra encuesta lo
situaba en el peor índice de aprobación
de todo el mandato con el
38%. hoy Joe biden martes ha anunciado
que se presentará las elecciones de 2024
en un vídeo de unos tres minutos y vamos
a resumir ese vídeo con los 30 segundos
finales escuchemos a Joe biden
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ese estilo tan distinguible de la
carrera política en Estados Unidos Marta
vamos entonces a un repaso general por
las cabeceras digitales de los
principales medios estadounidenses sobre
esta noticia que además nos cayó muy
temprano en la madrugada de América
Latina Así es Ángela hemos destacado
cinco cabeceras de 5 grandes medios
estadounidenses vamos a empezar con el
Washington post Eso sí vamos a
escuchar titulares que son muy
semejantes a lo largo de toda la crónica
el Washington post titula vaiden anuncia
que se postulará para candidato en 2024
tiene la intención como escuchábamos en
el vídeo de campaña de terminar el
trabajo que ha empezado durante estos
cuatro años cuando el país estaba
azotado por la pandemia de coronavirus y
sus consecuencias fatales para la
economía pero también biden dice que
quiere redemocratizar Estados Unidos y
alejarlo de esos extremismos de los
aliados de Donald Trump es un anuncio
clave en su carrera también política
porque Joe biden Lleva más de 50 años en
activo también hemos destacado el New
York Times que hace una especie de
directo donde va actualizando todas las
noticias relativas a esta a esta
oficialización de la candidatura que
titula vaiden buscará la reelección
preparando una posible revancha con
Donald Trump destaca que el anuncio de
Joe biden y que él mismo ha dicho que
los extremistas del maga del make
American son los que tienen que alejarse
porque
amenazan la democracia en Estados Unidos
y que van a combatir ese extremismo
presentándose a las elecciones y además
dice este artículo del New York Times
que biden no ha tenido un candidato
opositor dentro del partido demócrata y
que por eso hay un consenso Claro en las
filas demócratas para que sea él quien
se postule para presidente en 2024 por
otro lado destacamos el usate today que
titula el secreto peor guardado en
Washington sale a la luz
anuncia la campaña a la reelección de
2024 el presidente ha hecho oficial algo
que se esperaba desde hace meses y que
había manifestado la intención de
hacerlo pero nunca de manera oficial
hasta este martes la CNN titula biden se
une a Trump en la carrera de 2024 la
oferta de biden para esta carrera
presidencial es salvar la democracia la
de Trump hacer que biden no tenga un
segundo mandato y salvar a Estados
Unidos de ese sangrado de la Democracia
que dicen que ha hecho biden y por otra
parte el Boston glove destaca byden
anuncia su candidatura a la reelección
un camino tranquilo para biden en el
camino a la reelección en el partido
demócrata Mire es Interesante como ella
hasta los medios de comunicación hablan
de un duelo que sería Trump biden Pese a
que hay más precandidatos Pese a que hay
figuras como rondes antes que se
perfilan con mucha fuerza para estas
elecciones así que bueno Habría que ver
qué es lo que pasar para el 2024 pero
concretamente el medio político dice que
los demócratas están esperanzados en
reeditar el duelo en Trump aunque como
usted dice Pues es que no había más así
es Ángela y lo titula político los
demócratas disfrutan de la revancha
Trump y vaivén en el seno del partido
demócrata se han redoblado las
esperanzas después de que Trump fuera
acusado penalmente por soborno a la
actriz pornos dormida Daniels y que
viéramos esa imagen de él entrando en
ese juzgado de Manhattan además dice
desde el partido demócrata que Trump se
presente
maximiza las opciones de Joe biden en
esa carrera polarizadora dice ante una
campaña que va a ser de tantos extremos
biden sigue siendo la mejor opción eso
dice político claro que también se
pronuncian los medios conservadores si
Ángela llevamos a empezar con el Wall
Street journal que titula también el
presidente biden lanza su campaña la
reelección y dice que baiden
enfrentamientos en contra Por una parte
la aprobación de su mandato según una
encuesta hecha en este mismo medio solo
el 15% de los encuestados en un sondeo
dicen que el país va en la buena
dirección Bajo su gobierno los
republicanos le culpan de la alta
inflación y La caótica retirada de
Afganistán Por otra parte la Fox news
destaca pues esos bajos índices de
aprobación también que se ha enfrentado
a cosas como la pandemia la guerra en
Ucrania el lanzamiento de misiles
balísticos en Corea del Norte o la
crisis entre Taiwán y China y por otra
parte el New York post otro medio bien
conservador dice textualmente que biden
se presenta a pesar de las abrumadoras
señales de que los estadounidenses
quieren que renuncie se hacen eco de
esto también y muy rápidamente Marta
Porque nos quedamos sin tiempo los
medios internacionales si Ángela hemos
destacado el país El guardián hemos
destacado el South china morning post y
lemont que titulan este mismo este mismo
anuncio no biden se presenta la
candidatura
un anuncio que ya se sabía Y que era un
Secreto a voces ya es oficial Eso sí el
morning post dice que tiene el camino
avanzado en el en el partido demócrata
mientras los republicanos pues empiezan
esa carrera por las primarias para
definir Cuál será su candidato que más
que probablemente será Donald Trump no
ha dado tiempo para la creatividad de
esta noticia hace poco más de dos horas
que nos enteramos y seguro No claro y en
todas las reacciones están que corren
con esta noticia gracias a usted Marta
por llegar con prontitud y con el
análisis gracias Ángela